it is great to be here
it is my incredibly great pleasure to
introduce the host for this evening the
ever-loving incredibly charming science
communicator extraordinaire Neil
deGrasse Tyson
[Applause]
Eugene Mirman
[Applause]
let's so just to be clear these Startalk
lives were birthed in the Eugene Mirman
Comedy Festival there's a whole county
official named after this guy
and since Startalk has always had a
professional comedian as my co-host he
figured that would fit nicely into that
format and so we're here as a
continuation of that series yes and let
me bring out two comedians the first one
very funny man he is the author of how
to be black and he was supervising
producer on The Daily Show with Trevor
Noah ladies and gentlemen baratunde a
third son
coolest first name at Barratt Tunde yeah
that'd be the coolest name there's a
very good I might I might take it the
next guest a very funny woman she is the
host of NPR's ask me another ladies and
gentlemen Oh Fira Eisenberg
[Applause]
[Applause]
I don't know if we pre advertise what
the title of this evening is title this
evening is let's make America smart
again
[Applause]
so we combed the land for people who
could give us insight into this and one
such person is dr. professor John
Holdren the former science advisor to
President Obama John Holdren come on
[Applause]
at the moment he's professor of
Environmental Policy up at Harvard and
he came down just for this but thanks
thanks John thank you also from the
Obama administration we have a biologist
Jo Handelsman Joe come on out
[Applause]
she was Associate Director for science
at the Office of Science and Technology
Policy under President Obama and now
she's a microbiologist at the University
of Wisconsin right cheeseheads
yes yes so this event will be in three
parts
initially we'll talk about Earth and
keeping track of what's going on and why
talk about the science and the policy
related to that next we will talk about
biology and all of how that affects
health and get inside the National
Institutes of Health and what they're
all about and why and we'll end up with
a final segment on the future the future
of space the future AI robotics and so
we're gonna do it all all the science
that matters in this country and we're
doing it now this is a live broadcast
here at the Count Basie Theatre
let's do it
arrived well Earth Day is in April Earth
Day April 22nd and it coincides with the
science march on Washington so so John
Earth Day began in 1970 right why why
not 1960 surely people cared about Earth
in 1960 no people did but what had
happened during the course of the 60s is
there were the whole series of
environmental disasters they've got
people so we need disaster you have to
protect so we don't know how to protect
something proactively this asked for his
help the Tioga River catching fire Oh
was one that would that'll do that oh
yeah Oh Lake Erie
becoming totally clogged with algae so
that most of the fish were dying was and
of course the air pollution in the Los
Angeles basin getting worse and worse so
that on most days you couldn't see the
mountains in fact I was at Caltech in
the early 1970s acid in there in
Pasadena I'd been there for six months
before I knew there were mountains right
behind okay so Joe you were what you
worked with John Holdren and the Office
of Science and Technology Policy like
what is what is OSTP I think most people
have never heard of it
so why what's what what do you do not do
well we obviously didn't advertise
ourselves very much our job was to mix
policy and science and that meant two
things some of it was policy for science
how to make our science enterprise as
strong as it could be using policy to
shape it but the other side was using
science to shape policy on issues that
weren't obviously about science before
like what like forensics forensic
science is supposedly based on science
but in fact there's not that much
science behind it and so we brought the
science to bear on that issue and so
John you're you were appointed by Obama
yeah did you have to be approved by the
Senate
yes but there are two different jobs
involved science advisor to the
president is not subject to Senate
confirmation director of the White House
Office of Science and Technology Policy
is subject did you have a title and I
had both titles but I could start
serving as the president's science
advisor on Inauguration Day 2009 took
two months to get confirmed as director
of OSTP and in those two months I
couldn't sit in the director's office
couldn't give any orders anybody in OSTP
but I could talk to the president Wow
so glad this bureaucracy is going to be
so so how was Obama
among the presidents with regard to
science would you say well I think
President Obama was the most science
savvy president since Thomas Jefferson
Thomas Jefferson of course was his own
science advisor whose badass but the
president came into office understanding
how and why science and technology
matter for the economy for public health
for the environment for national
security it was pretty low that people
got it he understood it
all right so Thursday I still forgive me
don't really know what you're supposed
to do on Earth Day like what are you
supposed to do I think you're supposed
to draw a picture of the earth and then
get it on a tote bag
walk on the appreciate walk on the earth
touch the earth you know it'd be a good
thing on earth they eat a stick of pot
butter yeah look at a baby for as long
as it'll let you has biological motive
doesn't it absolutely some of us think
it should be renamed soil day because
it's about the earth but the most
important thing on the earth is the soil
that's where all of our food comes from
don't you study soil I do how many want
to call it soil day water was pretty
important yeah yeah I can go more than a
week without soil but the earth is dead
really fast without soil so you can't
use yourself as the standard sorry it's
okay Neil you can't go for a week
without air air air is really important
yeah that's minutes without yeah so so
when I think of Earth Day 1970 in that
same here
the EPA Environmental Protection Agency
was founded and so was NOAA the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
smart gear for people caring so what I'm
trying to understand
well I'm slightly more serious know one
of the things we're hearing about the
earth know one of
no more serious than your going for a
week without soil oh okay no more
serious know what it's really about I
think is talking with folks and
reminding them about all the ways we
depend on air and soil and water and
sunlight and you know the trouble is
most people today
too many people think that food
materializes denovo on supermarket
shelves you know they think that when
you plug something into the wall the
electricity is coming from right behind
the wall and they think that most pest
control is done by pesticides they think
that most availability of water is
through canals and dams they just don't
get it that we depend on the earth for
our well being and that's what it's
really about you guys worked in an
office that should be household
conversation and it's not how come well
I think partly because we backed up the
president the president was the face of
OSTP in many ways because he rolled out
the policy he represented it I remember
how when was it when C everett Koop told
people how to not or how to use condoms
or whatever I forgot the details as as
what was just vital again
okay I believe you told people to
masturbate and then the president had to
take it back that was totally wrong no
no that was the net hhn yeah that was
the next Joycelyn elders yeah yeah
Jocelin elders I remember yeah why do I
even know his name then
so he was around I think in the in the
AIDS era where so so we all knew his
name yeah yeah and and so so why didn't
we know your name because you're you you
must have been out of it everybody I
know knows John Holdren and
work with the guy well but I know a few
people who are outside the White House
and they all think that he's a hero well
so here's the thing birthday do was
somehow in the air no pun intended
a sense of concern for earth as a planet
that came out it was right right in the
middle when we were going to the moon
right I think we went to explore the
moon we looked back and discovered earth
for the first time and in that discovery
earth became a focus of our about
concern and of our we want to preserve
this spaceship floating there in the
void we basically took a planet-sized
selfie yeah basically that's right from
the quarter million miles away so it
looks like we we exploited that fact
legislatively absolutely that that blue
marble photo that selfie that baritone
day is just referred to was critical and
so EPA gets formed apparently not under
any controversy right I guess well you
know it was interesting that you know
President Nixon actually thought it was
important to do that and I think he was
Republican last I remember yeah it's
true
it was one of his better moments today
he'd be considered a communist so so the
the mission of the EPA to ensure that
all Americans are protected from risks
to human health and to the environment
from where they live where they learn
and where they work so so this sounds
like an important organization very
important organization and one which has
been built up since its inception and
which has done on the whole pretty good
job and what's the relationship between
NOAA and the EPA well NOAA is basically
an environmental monitoring and a
science organization they're responsible
for understanding what's happening in
the oceans what's happening in the
atmosphere the National Weather Service
is part of a NOAA for example so our
weather forecasts come from NOAA and by
the way a member of Congress once
famously said I don't know why we have
to fund NOAA we have the Weather Channel
that's called unclear on the concept
so alright so both organizations exist
today and what can you comment on their
support in Congress well it's mixed
obviously NOAA and EPA have had strong
support through both Republican and
Democratic administrations all over the
years right but now they are faced with
severe budget cuts most severe in EPA if
president Trump's budget is accepted by
Congress and that's not a foregone
conclusion he's proposed a budget for
EPA but Congress has to approve it but
that budget cuts
EPA's total funding by over 30% and the
research and development organization in
EPA is cut by 50% in that proposed
budget NOAA's budget is also being cut
particularly in respect to ocean
monitoring and research climate data now
you don't have anything to do with that
because you're not in Washington anymore
that's right so why am I even asking you
this question
a lot of people are asking me what is
going to be the role of Science and
Technology in the new administration
guard we're gonna ask you that I want a
staff of a politician is there
politician in the house
[Applause]
hello all right
senator Cory Booker New Jersey
[Applause]
so you can't come up in my house Jersey
I got word that you were in Jersey hid
your word crossed from the dark side of
the Hudson I crossed the move into the
light welcome to New Jersey it's great
to have thank you delighted to be in
your home state senator proof your
former mayor of Newark Technic that
can't have been easy it was the best
part of Cedar there you go and so you're
sitting senator in mid term right now
correct Thank You New Jersey yes okay so
so we have people who previously serve
and you were indicates while they were
served well their names might not be
publicly known by their heroic people
that made Obama probably one of the
greatest science presidents we've ever
had did the people got around Street
Bank because of the folksy put in place
yes and so so we're now talking about a
president's budget because a lot of this
I think is just a mystery to so many
people who certainly a mystery to me so
the president puts out a budget and
doesn't the Congress kind of have to go
along with most of what that is you read
the article one branch of the
Constitution the first branch of
government described as the Congress
they have extraordinary powers they set
the budget so the president suggests or
present something to Congress but
Congress actually makes the decisions
that is like a constitutional Smackdown
that was still polite
Sooey that by the way that we could do
the hamilton - so you and your fellow 99
other senators actually wield mule power
on that budget extraordinary power
extraordinary power well I was aghast at
the at the President's budget I think it
was one of the most scary documents it
basically put forth in one document a
reflection of what his values are which
frankly if you look at his budget the
so-called skinny budget and the way he
tears apart critical programs that
affect every element of Americans lives
yeah even the base for the people that
voted for him it was there was a patent
betrayal of those people who supported
him and would in terms of creating jobs
and economic strength is what he
preached in his his campaigning days it
would have really debilitated this
nation's ability to compete globally in
a world that now is a knowledge-based
economy which means science and
innovation and technology is so critical
so to take away the government's role in
that would really completing both hands
behind our back as we're competing with
the Chinese and the German and the
Japanese were making significant
investments in fact beginning to
outstrip America when it comes to
investing in R&D so what is what is the
I want to compare sort of what were some
of the successes for under EPA and NOAA
in Obama that might be at risk right now
well I just want to let people know I
mean everything we touch represents your
public dollars I mean everything here
from the batteries to the touchscreen to
the GPS the origin of all this science
and technology that the private sector
is now using to create thousands of jobs
is is public sector investments in
science technology and it hardly anybody
knows that hardly buddy knows that
dollar invested affect all of us
probably our fiscal conservatives I had
to be when I was the mayor of Newark
every taxpayer dollar was precious the
reality is is the best return on
investment for a taxpayer dollar one of
the best ones you could get in
government investments is in things like
the National Institute of Health
it sucks investing
to get almost more than double the
return in terms of long-term economic
growth for our economy and so to savage
those programs to cut them so they're
people who don't recognize that the
government is actually a good place
where some kinds of money gets spent
rather than saying the government should
have no money at all yeah well let's
take a step back in the APA I mean we I
believe in the principles of a free
market but Newark for example their
environment is a testimony to the free
market run amok in other words the River
Chris a river is toxic the soil of
Newark is full of lead the the the
oxygen we have terrible asthma rates and
those are caused by companies that
weren't properly regulated pouring
toxins into the world and destroying not
just the health of in the environment
but also the fiscal competitiveness of
the city in the long term so by the EPA
being savaged like it is not just the
research and development side but just
holding people accountable for the laws
that they're breaking out there and the
hurting environment actually it costs
all of us money so Vince is a message
that needs to get out there okay so
you're a senator with who was elected to
office and you don't have a formal
science background so who's gonna listen
although I have a degree in political
science
so so you have it so there are advisors
there's the National Academy of Sciences
Office of Science and Technology Policy
so you we would like to think that when
they speak the public listens and heats
but somehow that's not happening and I
don't think any of us understand why so
what's up with that well I think that it
is really important now more than ever
and I think a lot of folks learn this
with this last election that the only
thing necessary for evil to be
triumphant is for good people to do
nothing right we've learned that
retweeting is just not gonna cut it
and so the age-old wisdom which I
decided the reality is is we did not
have an activist citizenry and and a lot
of folks and you were - we were joking
before about there's a concept of love
but patriotism by definition is love of
country love is not a beaten word it
demands action and sacrifice and so if
you love your country you've got to stay
engaged issues you've got to stay then
you've got to let your your elected
officials know that hey you're gonna be
overseeing a budget in fact the budget
of this country runs out on April 28th
and the budget decisions are gonna be
made probably on a continuing resolution
what are you going to prioritize if
you're not speaking up and letting your
voice be heard and engaging in the
process then you're basically
surrendering the precious space like the
what we're just talking about so let me
just anchor this
data so in order to make an informed
decision-making form protest even you
need data and NOAA is responsible for
many many satellites in orbit around the
earth monitoring climate for example and
you would think that this would be
sufficient so that people will then hear
about the day to learn about the data
and act upon the data as citizen
scientists if you will so what where's
the disconnect here well first of all
the public actually understands climate
change better than many members of the
Congress do he's no longer working in
the government now so you could say that
okay no but it's true that's what polls
show you know polls show and I said this
to President Obama at one point polls
showed that in the range of two-thirds
of Americans believe that climate change
is real substantially caused by humans
already doing harm we need to do
something about it two-thirds by the way
only 50% believe evolution this effect
and when I told the president that and I
said this was he was saying you
scientists have to do a better job
educating the public and I said well
we've done pretty well on climate change
and it's more than evolution he said
that's no consolation so it's not a
hundred percent so people they seem to
be sort of in sort of denial of data
that they don't like well it's almost
like they're afraid of what the data is
gonna say I mean we have laws in
Congress that were shocking to me that I
found out where we're blocking even
studying things like course we're
blocking even the studying of gun
violence and understanding the effects
of it and
and so the supporters of blocking gun
violence and so the question is why and
I want to I want to be very blunt with
some of the things that we have to
understand there are large moneyed
interests large corporate interests in
this country that are very invested into
the status quo right now and on
elections they spend billions and
billions of dollars supporting people
who will to protect fossil fuel
industries and others protect the status
quo so you can't expect it with that
much money be important to the system
that the people that often get elected
as a result of that won't be protecting
that despite the evidence and try to do
everything they can to fight the
evidence like the tobacco industry for
so long they would fund scientists who
had come up with funky science that was
wrong and tried to debunk or at least
confuse people as to what the day that
was showing about cigarette smoke I'm so
Joe if you you like for a while worked
in infectious diseases is that right or
you have you you were part of the
programs that taught people about it
yeah in OSTP we dealt with it several
epidemics like Ebola and Zika virus and
we handled it John and I were where they
keep people at OSTP um so so that's a
case where if something goes wrong
people get sick and die so there's an
immediate cause and effect and climate
change has a little bit more of a
horizon but if sea levels rise and you
start flooding seems to me that's cause
and effect
well when heat waves and droughts and
wildfires burning larger and larger
areas you know in the Arctic campus are
way more than the billions of dollars
worth of advertising I think we might be
looking at this the wrong way first of
all funky science sounds amazing
I don't know why you dis not second John
you started you collect the EPA and know
were born out of rivers on fire maybe
they're trying to return to that level
of disaster and urgency to inspire us so
I know it's happening I mean
you know the reasons so many Americans
now believe that climate change is real
and dangerous if they're experiencing it
in their lives they're seeing it on
their TV sets they're seeing it on their
iPads and it's stunning if you look at
the expansion of the areas afflicted by
extreme heat every summer if you look at
the areas burned by wildfires for the
first time in modern times the tundra is
burning in the Arctic the tundra is
burning that never happened before
yeah it never happened before in the
period when we were looking I went to a
doctor for a science cold and she told
me it was global warming I swear to you
the Germans are seeing the financial
impact of climate change right now so we
have most people understand we have a
massive fishing industry in New Jersey
what's happening with the acidification
of our oceans the warming of the oceans
they're seeing fish that you know useful
to find off the coast of New Jersey are
now being found further up in
Connecticut over named New England is
complaining because they're seeing
lobsters and other things moving further
and further and and so but more than
that we are at state that lives in flood
areas and now the flood maps literally
are now you're seeing what were used to
be 100-year floods happening with more
frequency which is costing New Jerseyans
a lot more money okay so I like what you
were saying that who said it that maybe
we're we are returning to the pre 1970
state of circumstances where we've got
to drop low before we recover as one
they're trying to inspire us man I think
well the disasters are trying to inspire
us I said not interesting way to think
about it yeah is the only way to stay
snake
so do you think maybe it would help to
just light a few local rivers we need to
light rivers that like Trump would come
across walks like more alive on fire
river up my golf courses on fire
is it too late no I don't think it's too
late and I think the because the river
on fire and that's all kind of local
stuff right and we talk about climate
change we're talking about planet-wide
yes so that requires planet-wide
cooperation and participation so is it
is it too late well there is one study
that showed that people believe in
climate change based more on the three
previous days of weather than anything
else and so there so we just like three
really warm April's away from people
being like bye let's fix this
so I'm sorry return to this point that
the cynicism is killing me we are a
nation that that the majority of us the
majority of Republicans believe that
climate change is real the disconnect is
not the people of this nation realizing
if there's a problem the disconnect is
you know King used to always say and one
of the more more elephant than I could
ever say the problem today what we all
have to repent but recently Martin
Luther King we're gonna think it will
let the repent for is not the vitriolic
words and violent actions of the bad
people
it's the appalling silence and inaction
of the good people and so that's the
problem is that it's not that hold
Republicans that the majority of them as
you said believe climate change is real
millennial Republicans are so far
progressive on more progressive on these
issues on everything and everything all
issues and by the way the only major
political party on the planet Earth
every other nation there right party and
they're Left Party believe in climate
change the official elected Republican
leadership is the only one on the planet
Earth that does not officially believe
in climate change
that's cause American exceptionalism
that leadership on a different planet
[Applause]
let me give you an example this is this
is simple you know I'm always a big
believer the power of the people is
greater than the people in power but
folks don't exercise that power as Alice
Walker said the most common way people
give up their power is not realizing
they have it in the first place and so
the cynicism that gets thrown around is
actually a toxic state of being because
it's surrendering your ability to make
change because things can't be changed
what we this is something very simple if
just Millennials alone but Barack Obama
said this in a speech to Howard students
forget Republican or Democrat have just
millennial generation the biggest
population bubble coming up
demographically right now if they just
voted the same levels that X generous
did 40 50 percent in midterm elections
the entire Congress would change and so
this is not complicated look at the
young people and said you don't need to
occupy anything just knowing what is
right to do and I fear this I get that
and remembering that in the 60s huge
protests all the time in every major
city campus unrest it was a time where
citizenry was trying to take back the
government and I get that and you're
getting some of that now but at the end
of the day it comes down to policy
that's what it comes down to doesn't it
I mean right what policies are in place
that we can all agree to let's solve
these problems but you could win fights
like I came in and I actually took heat
even back here in New Jersey for arguing
I said okay I need to figure out a deal
to strike with Republicans and I work
with a lot of my colleagues on this and
saying hey the problem is oil and gas
industry get all kind of tax credits for
it for innovations well yeah but
renewable energy which we are losing
ground to the Chinese and the Germans
and their innovation their technology
the jobs of the future we're losing
ground because the tax credits for wind
and solar are one-year they're not
predictable tax
as the industry needs and so we fought
with an exchange we allowed the export
of oil something we had bought that in
exchange for seven years of predictable
attack credit well soon as Congress did
that what what anything's happened to
the solar and wind industry the United
States boom the investments are going up
the innovation is going up so that the
art of compromise it see we won that
battle in Congress it's not something
that made the front pages of newspapers
but we're in there every day fighting
and the thing that we need from the
public because I watched this has only
been 100 days the Trump administration
but people don't realize the day
Congress change the new Congress came in
one of the first things the Republicans
tried to do in the house was to remove
the watchdogs the ethics watchdogs and
it was the public that so was outraged
that they stopped them in their tracks
and they reverse course I've seen that a
number of times since then that the
public and the press exposing what's
happening is helping things back and you
and I both know history when it comes to
science the ability for the right poets
the right inspiration to prick the moral
consciousness the urgency of people
whether it's Kennedy talking about going
to the moon which was fueled science
like crazy or just simple Americans well
known people that have powerful
platforms like Neil deGrasse Tyson
bringing I mean you are you are a guy
there's getting folk walk on science
issues and I think that that's really
powerful role of woken folks well not
what I'm trying to do is through forums
such as this and everything else is just
try to not tell people what is true
about the universe but empower people to
understand why and in that way they can
take ownership of that knowledge without
even having to reference me right if all
it was was this is true cuz Tyson said
so that I failed as an educator you say
this is true because angles to be and
this cause that that cause that then you
own that information and that then gets
shared and I'm not even in that picture
I don't have to be at that point and
then everybody takes command of their
lives and of the country in which we
live
[Applause]
it also it also helps a lot of us not
just wake up every day screaming because
we know that there's someone out there
that sounds sane okay so so one point
Carl Sagan was once asked about Sagan
yeah the senator earlier onset billions
and billions did you hear that yeah yeah
he'd actually said that I heard that he
was asked with regard to superheroes
what was his favorite superhero and he's
not a fan of superheroes because
superheroes as they're portrayed it
gives us the excuse to not do anything
about problems in the world because
you're just waiting around for someone
who has the power to solve it while
you're eating popcorn watching movies
and so so so to to the Senators point
quoting was it Alice Walker the biggest
it's the power you don't know you
actually have that is the failure yes I
paraphrase but yes I'll talk the most
common way we give up our powers not
realizing we have it first not even
knowing you had already seated it to
someone else who's using it yes possibly
against you most likely if you check out
of a system that system is gonna work
against it's like when Time magazine
said that we were all Person of the Year
I was lame that was like the lame is
worst person of the year ever or was it
the best know it's it's it's what's the
generation where there are no losers and
everyone is a winner I think
they have the editorial board in that
moment yeah yeah yeah do you think Carl
Sagan secretly liked Green Lantern
though I'll check people coming up in
the next segment we're going to explore
and in fact celebrate the latest
advances in medical research genetics
and health when Startalk returns live
from the scalp AZ theater New Jersey the
universe is the man though the universe
is a gender-neutral human who we all do
your eugene is one of the proud
representatives of great tradition in
america he is in the immigrant from
where are you from sir would you I
forget Russia you're from Russia yeah
yes yeah yeah so US citizens you can't
get rid of me yeah
that's right so it's a first-generation
immigrant either first-generation
immigrant you born in another country
you came here yeah and you're a to be
president but that's fine on that
subject I will add I just did this
homework that the average decade by
decade average of first-generation
immigrants in the United States since
1900 is about 10% since one in 10
Americans were born somewhere else at
any given time across the century now
let's ask another question what
percentage of American winners of the
Nobel Prize in the sciences was a
first-generation immigrant a third of
all American Nobel prizes in chemistry
physics and human physiology were
foreign-born well so they're three times
as represented in the science this
highest prize of science then they
aren't even in the population well give
you an example of this so people who
come out of lobby in Washington I love
when people don't hire lobbyists but
they come down themselves I see lots of
New Jerseyans come down and when I see
college professors from Princeton to
Mike University Stanford come and they
come to me and they say look this is
crazy we bring these folks in the
brightest minds to study at our
universities on student visas we use our
resources giving the best education on
the planet earth as soon as that student
visa runs out what is our country now
saying to them get out of our nation
right and and that's ridiculous
when we have a country that attracts us
greatness and incentive that
I would like to point out on that
particular point that President Obama
proposed in 2011 to staple a green card
to every graduate degree in science
earned by a foreign citizen just staple
the green card to the degree well they
have in around Stanford I was told
there's a billboard that says you can't
get your h-1b visa you know stay come to
Canada and so other countries are seeing
yet we used to do to accelerate ahead of
the rest of the planet Earth and one of
those things they saw was they had
policies that try to attract the
brightest of the globe and they're
saying okay America's not gonna do that
anymore we want to do that because we
want to leave it's just an all fairness
Newt Gingrich said that as well just
staple it green cards
what just so you know I just wanted to
just be fair out there I am Canadian and
all my Canadian friends now treat me
like I have a illness how's it going
yeah that's some people on the stage and
our foreign-born
yeah and I actually I'm only on a green
card yeah I'm a new mom I have an anchor
baby
I've got science advisors here of a
politician here what clueless in how
advice is obtained received and enacted
or not
what is that dynamic here because I
don't know well first of all I had a
great relationship with Democratic
senators but not Republican senator a
few Republican senators okay many many
fewer but I mean part of the way it
works is there's a lot of interaction
between the scientists and government
and the Congress we take the scientists
and government testify all the time in
committees or in front of the Senate in
the house you're on a committee what
sure you're on the Science Committee yes
I'm on I want two committees one that's
called the Commerce Committee but the
full name includes commerce technology
science a lot of those things and I'm on
the Environment Committee Environment
and Public Works so I'm on two of the
main committees to deal with issues of
science technology innovation and they
hear a lot of testimony but they also
meet individually with scientists and
technologists from not just the White
House but from the Department of Energy
from the National Science Foundation
from NOAA their staff meet all the time
these are all the people they who the
Senate approved yeah so so you so they
can just summon you at will absolutely
and just bitch-slap you when they feel
like
well you know when I used to I will
comment that on days that I was
testifying we used to call that pinata
day in yah today they swing at you with
a big stick and they hope to break you
open and some candy will fall out
did they ever hope you would just help
their kids with their science homework
because I once testified in front of the
Science Committee of the Senate and you
either were there where you weren't a
senator yet I was I would be there sir
since I'm a citizen NASA to test the
drive I didn't feel like a pinata I felt
that they were just kind of gathering
information though it's commenting on
the value of exploration specifically
space exploration into a universe that
has unlimited resources especially kinds
of resources that on earth we fight wars
over so I just thought I would like this
fact yeah and so so I was intrigued
because I didn't feel like I was making
much of a difference and I'm just kind
of going through motions and then they
were going through motions and I didn't
feel their energy so I don't know so it
does this work
when you give advice are they actually
listening sometimes sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't Corey when they
give you advice how do you listen
so I there's a serious problem with our
politics writ large but there is a
massive area on these science committees
in which I find bipartisan space to work
with and that's everything from you know
I was I came to Washington I saw that
the the technology for drones that we
were losing all these companies because
America our regulations were strangling
that industry I told the head of the FAA
if you were around during or Bulova
right we would have never gotten off the
ground and they were literally going to
other countries like France and we're
years and years ahead of us in utilizing
drones for mine surveys for technology
and so I found partners there nuclear
energy next generation nuclear power is
thank you for pronouncing nuclear
correctly thank you very much
other nations are now far more
attractive to those nuclear scientists
because of our regulatory framework that
doesn't look to the next generation of
nuclear energy which is far safer eats
that spent nuclear rods from other other
from from the current version and we
were going to be losing out on our edge
in that technology here's something that
we can imagine laws about nuclear we
need to make some loose nuclear energy
we need to be doing as a nation is we
need to begin to have a government that
moves at the speed of innovation in
other words the whole third sector of
this show right get back to the okay
what I want to know is is one of the
bipartisan points of agreement helps the
National Institutes of Health so is that
one that's got to be in there somewhere
look like this wow that's a too long to
say yes that's enough
we are screwing up in the larger sense
in our investment in biotech and coming
from a biotech and innovation and health
space state where Jersey New Jersey is
we are really screwing up in so many
ways of this system we're screwing up
and not investing in it other nations
are beginning to pull ahead in their
investments in this area we're screwing
up and in the way the free market is
contorting and making people's
prescription drugs way too high price I
can go through the ways of this this
space frustrates the hell out of me but
what bothers me most is this the fact
that Howell timer's my father died of
Parkinson's just a few years ago all of
this that is costing us these illnesses
that are costing us so much money we
could be investing more in the cures of
these diseases we could lead humanity
out of the darkness of the pain like we
look at other diseases we conquer but
we're just not making a commitment as a
society to put our resources or energy
or talent our spirits job it sounds like
you can combine that problem with an
analysis and throw in some economics and
then you have an argument that has no
holes that everyone just agrees with and
then you create the policy then you move
on well why isn't that happening sense
Neal some of it is happening in the
Obama administration we started the
brain initiative which is making
tremendous advances in understanding how
the brain works which will help us
ultimately figure out how to cure or
avoid all time
does that still exist or is it just no
it still exists maybe because I haven't
found out about it yet so Joe what can
you think of biomedical advances that
that more people need to know about well
one of the big initiatives that I worked
on in fact was my first initiative in
the White House was precision medicine
which is the idea of using big data
about big populations of people to
tailor medicine treatment and prevention
to the individual so if you can sort of
parse people into lots of different
groups and based on whether it's their
zip codes or their genome or their
microbiome something like that you can
then make predictions about their health
and this is really the future of
medicine but I had kind of an
interesting experience this is my first
memo to the president we John and I
wrote this memo and then we're invited a
few days later very quickly to the Oval
Office to meet with the president you
got to write memos to the president can
we tell which ones will commit crimes
and arrest them beforehand yeah okay so
we had this great meeting and the
president clearly had gotten the
precision medicine so I walked out
feeling pretty good it said John you got
it and this is pretty cool the next week
I was sort of perusing some old
legislation I came across 2006
legislation written by Senator Obama on
precision medicine
but that I think is an example of a
bipartisan issue because when we rolled
out precision medicine we had as many
Republicans as Democrats at the event
and just in December the 21st century
cures bill which supports precision
medicine and the brain initiative and
several other things passed the Senate
ninety five to five thank you very much
to me that health would be the most
bipartisan thing going but then I'm
surprised to see a proposal to reduce
the funding to the National Institutes
of Health so I don't understand why
almost six billion dollars yep so Kakori
what's up with that
it is I've literally been in the scrum
during these large budget deals where
that exasperatingly you're fighting to
try to say how can we be funding X Y or
Z like these broken programs that don't
do anything and we're not funding
something as obvious as this that
frankly I work in a body that we're all
getting old it's kind of a one of the
more thoughtful senior bodies where a
lot of these diseases are gonna be
visited upon us and so I don't
understand it do you forget about if you
don't care about this country and you're
not as much of a patriot as we all
should be but think about your family
think about yourself why aren't we
making more of an investment and even
worse again I keep repeating this over
and over again but we've heard all about
this president promising that we're
gonna win big lis but but
the reality is our competitors are
making massive investments in terms of
percentage of their GDP investing in
these things they're overtaking us
they're gonna catch us and overtake us
and so I just look at what China is
doing and what Germany is doing and what
Russia is even doing in terms of what
they're investing in okay bring it let
your trim the inner Jersey just so the
day I realized and this is a pretty I'm
gonna call it upsetting but disturbing
day for me when I look back and add
America's a presence in the space race
okay from 1957 wrong words the launch of
Sputnik until we landed on the moon
essentially every decision we made to go
into space and what to do there was
reactive to what Russia the Soviet Union
had already done or was already planning
every single move they put in a first
satellite we but ever sell if they put
up a dog we put up a chimp they put up a
human then we put up a human they put
and we are reacting and every time at
every turn and I've wondered can a
democracy
be proactive or do we have to wait
around until we feel threatened and only
then do the Pistons align for us to act
the way we should
basic theater you're talking about the
marriage of science and policy and I've
got a great panel up here what we're
trying to do is make America smart again
trying to find out science policy come
together to effect change for the
greater good of us all and Eugene
we're here for you yes thank you but
still part of the Eugene Mirman Comedy
Festival get reset with me Baron Sunday
everybody yeah no fear Eisenberg
[Applause]
and I've got John Holdren and Jo
Handelsman both who worked in Obama's
Office of Science and Technology Policy
and very special guests who wandered off
the streets onto stage we have New
Jersey senator Cory Booker Murray you
know I hate to say anything defending
the u.s. space program but the Russians
never put up the Hubble we put up the
Hubble without any hole we have no but
you're talking about our reactive stance
through the six visits we've done a lot
of things ahead to the Russians right
now Hubble was peanuts compared with
putting people in space that's all I'm
saying cheese scientifically not at all
most of the budget NASA was always not
science so yeah we tried to fix that
care Parkinson's we would then
so Joe what more advances are coming
down the pike
what can we look for well I think one of
the big areas that I'm excited about is
microbiology because we're starting to
understand that not only human body but
all ecosystems on earth are driven in
part by their microbiomes which means
their collection of microorganisms the
microRNA that live on you and in you
yeah exactly
like mostly probably in your intestines
right that's where a lot of them are but
also the skin the years every orifice of
the body is you know you told anyone
under 30 that everyone over 50 at one
time would walk into something called a
phone booth take the receiver and put
this side to their ear and this side to
their mouth where a hundred other people
have done it that day so now you have
shared ear rats and mouths pill
[Laughter]
generation doesn't have all these
allergies and disease
we're like steeped in germs exactly the
issue that most microbes are not germs
they're not harmful to us they're only
about 80 species of germs and there are
thousands if not millions of other
species of microbes and so we don't
think of them as the good guys but in
fact they're keeping us healthy
controlling our behavior controlling our
vulnerability to disease all the time
but even I mean that I've read a lot of
a research on this I mean even things
like depression and a lot of things
we've been thinking have other actives
actually our gut microbiome is affecting
us so much of our well-being how we're
dealing fight us a whole frontier it is
an amazing frontier so she was saying
that there's some you correct me if I'm
wrong I know I'll get somebody's wrong
she was saying that their microbes in
you that actually like chocolate and
communicate this fact to your to your
eating desires and you say gee I want
some chocolate when in fact it's your
microbiome that's asking for that's
right we're driven by our bacteria to
tell you this and everything I'm reading
is there's a good gut bacteria in bed
but that and the bad gut bacteria really
breathes off of empty carbohydrates and
things like that
but if you really want to breathe better
gut bacteria you need to eat more fiber
more vegetables or plant-based diet
this gene editing tool CRISPR that I've
heard that's an acronym right yep
because this sounds like it's the future
of all biology well I think it's very
important because it lets us make very
very precise changes in genes or around
you this is a tool for laboratory
[Laughter]
concern about the ethics of that making
new life or altering life to your own
whims yeah well I think that was a big
issue when John and I were in the White
House was trying to figure out what are
the limits to what we're comfortable
with and one that was clear and the
president said this and his policy was
that we're not going to edit the germ
line which means the the embryos that
are forming so we're not going to create
heritable changes in people in the test
tube heritable would mean the ability to
transfer that from one generation to the
next that's right right and so we're
thinking more in terms of what used to
be called gene therapy where regular
tissue not your your sexual tissue but
your skin or your heart or your lungs
would be modified so we would only have
an effect in your lifetime but that
hasn't stopped the Chinese from doing
exactly the experiments we decided not
to do and affecting embryos and having
gene changes that will be passed on do
we have super soldiers I saw that yeah
it sounds like it might be real
or at least people that live off of
chocolate only yeah it seems to me you
can you can if you could modify the
individual you can you know we joke
about this and I'm not even a fan of it
but people are imagine if you're gonna
live on Mars just genetically modify you
so that everything that's different
about Mars is okay for your genetically
modified body and that way you don't
have to live in a hab module that's an
extreme case but clearly you could use
this to cure us of our traditional
diseases right and so the human body has
evolved over many millennia to be what
it is today with a few mistakes
certainly but we haven't evolved to be
on Mars so we're just gonna make it I
just put that out there because people
occasionally talk about it but is this
real and it's NIH funding this research
and does Congress know about this and
they be hired you learning about it now
watch West world okay can we delete the
Republican genes
I know that's mine confess it's mine
control them for it so what did so so is
there a and an awareness of the value of
that of that power incredibly about
value of that power yeah incredibly so
it's not to where I would want it to be
I would like us to get back to being a
science technology innovation leading
nation and and that's my frustration is
the excitement that I get when I hear a
scientist like this talk about what is
possible I wish we could somehow that
sort of expand the moral imagination in
this country about what we are capable
about in terms of leading the human race
into a into a safer to us stronger to a
more prosperous world for all of us and
and that's the challenge we have right
now I get back to this idea of what I
think you play a good role in and we all
have to accept responsibility in doing
is we are that we can't expect the world
to change unless we're willing to change
and be a part of that change and leave
that change and so we all should be
excited about science excited about
innovation the more we get excited about
it the more that will out the more we
demand or like the leaders are the more
more likely they are to respond to our
demands and so what do you see are they
are the barriers between that goal and
sort of making America smart in a way
that we become wise wise shepherds of
our future well look I do want to be
very blunt we were gonna have some very
tough fighting years ahead of us we've
got three plus years now of a president
who has made it clear on many of these
issues that he is contrary you know that
the Chinese made up global warming you
saw what the values at his budget he put
forward and so much of what I'm doing in
Washington right now still looking for
partnerships across the aisle to get
things done but I'm preparing to fight a
president that I think wants to take our
country back words in terms of science
innovation yeah but but so I mean I
don't beat politicians over the head you
know why because they're elected by an
electorate right so so you
beat him on the head but and even get
rid of him but then there's the matter
of the electorate that voted for them in
the first place
so so your gripe is not actually with
the president your gripe is with the 60
million people who voted for hell no in
fact I don't think you get anywhere as a
country when we are in the course of
demonizing each other I think what we
need to do I see this as a matter of
education if it's a matter if you're
yeah if you're actually saying this
policy will harm these people as they
don't know it then somebody's got to
educate them right and I'll give you two
quick examples one is this is why the
science March is so important because
when you saw that when you saw eight
people going I was down in Washington
for the women's March and people didn't
March around saying yet you know there
wasn't people with signs like the
Republicans in fact that I bumped into
women that were Republicans there that
were against a lot of policy issues but
a lot of this I saw no anti-republican
sign no they don't have that one and
there are a lot of innovative signs the
march on Washington you have people like
Strom Thurmond literally the longest
filibuster in the Senate is a a racist
rant by a man trying to block the civil
rights legislation but the march on
Washington listen to the speakers John
Lewis Martin Luther King they weren't
speaking against those folks they were
calling to the moral imagination of this
country and what my frustration is is
often we we are not engaged we look URI
eight in this incredible nation we have
the four most powerful words you can say
as a human being in fact only
four-and-a-half percent of humanity can
say I am an American and that comes
because of the labors and the sacrifices
and struggles of generations before and
this generation we see what happens when
we disconnect we see what's happening in
Washington result as a result of people
not voting I saw this one a pie graph
you know 50 you know what a 60 million
people voting for Hillary Clinton 57 for
Donald Trump million voting for Donald
Trump and 74 million other people like
oh my God look what just happened
and so so I'll give a very real example
of the EPA and what's happening right
now this isn't because of Donald Trump
this was happening under a great
president that wished he could change
him we in our nation right now where
Ronald Reagan reauthorized and Mitch
McConnell voted for a simple solution to
clean up Superfund sites these are
corporations that create the most toxic
spots on the in all of America there's a
Superfund in every state unfortunately
New Jersey has two most of them now that
that has that has elapsed that funding
has lapsed because this Congress now
suddenly not like Reagan not like the
old Mitch McConnell decides not to
reauthorize to clean up for that so
there's all of these so-called orphan
sites there's no Corporation anymore to
go after to clean them up but now we
have something called data when I was
mayor I learned this grilll quick a lot
of people coming to lead a lot of
commotion I said look and God We Trust
but everybody else bring me data you're
not a deity show me the numbers well now
we have longitudinal data from Princeton
University about what are the long-term
effects of living around a Superfund
site and we now know that if you all
have a child or have a Superfund site
there's about a 20% more likely of an
increase in autism 20% more likely of an
increase in birth defects so talk about
a threat to our children this isn't the
Russians or bases coming this is
problems we have right here in our
country that the only things is allowing
these to proliferate I have two
Superfund sites in Newark that are close
to where I live but the only thing
stopping us from doing something is
decisions being made in Congress but
most of us don't even know that fact we
also look we have the gene editing so we
can just get employed there first I
guess what I'm saying is that this is
the greatest country on the planet Earth
I don't care what Donald Trump says we
need to make it great again we are an
amazing country with reservoirs of love
and goodness and kindness but something
is missing and it was missing in the
1960s too it took geniuses I remember
Martin Luther King if you know that the
history the Taylor branch he comes out
of Birmingham jail after writing one of
the greatest pieces of American
literature
letters of early a.m. jail but he was
failing two young people with an
imagination Dorothea cotton and james
Bevel came up to him and said hey you're
failing here let us try something
different and the thing they did
different was to organize other yen
young people ages 8 to 18 to march
against Bull Connor to create the
spectacle of 10 12 14 16 year-olds
marching and what Bull Connor did he
sprayed the water hoses the next time he
really sparks on them but suddenly
people sitting home in Iowa and New
Jersey saw this spectacle going on
literally the the Soviet Union was
making fun of our democracy on the front
pages of their newspapers and it's so
awoke that the reservoir of love in this
country within days segregation fell in
Birmingham because this country when
they decide to do something nothing can
stand in our way
and so the challenge is it just sounds
like you got a sink really low before
you do so I think what we need to do is
find creative ways I mean you joking Lee
said snap chat about it but I'm sorry no
I've done the political should do it
science research about what influences
people to act and did you know the most
persuasive thing to get your friends to
vote is knowing if they're voting or not
it's literally talking to your circle of
friends more than one of my campaign
commercials in New Jersey if somebody
says hey everybody I've met Cory Booker
he's great I vote for him that's far
more persuasive than anything I could
put on TV or anything I can do we have
so much power and so this is my thing I
don't think we need to light rivers on
fire
what we need to do is ignite our own
spirits and and I promise you that that
light will cast away some darkness I
just think we all need to say what can I
do different this year around issues of
that I care about whether it's science
or super funds or space exploration pick
something and be a patriot and with love
and pursuit a bit of that end and you
will make more of a change than you
could ever imagine
[Applause]
give it to me
[Applause]
[Applause]
so what I want to know now is beyond nor
are we do we have the policy in place to
invent the future or again are only we
only reacting to bad things that have
happened in the past so JA let me begin
with you
how much duties of your office was to
have people think about tomorrow Allah
and and in fact you have on your list
space exploration when we entered office
we knew we had a challenge in space
exploration because a lot of the science
had gone out of NASA a lot of the
advanced technology had gone out of NASA
we had to rebalance NASA we said we were
putting the science back in rocket
science in fact you know we had we had a
bit of a struggle we did rebalance NASA
and a lot of Washington for eight years
eight years like that's like longer than
any science advisor ever in the history
of the universe well of course the
history of the science advisor doesn't
go back quite as far it goes back to the
the last term of Franklin D wrote a
second last term of Franklin D Roosevelt
so but I was the longest-serving science
advisor in that jury well sure and and
of course like everybody else unlike you
I had been watching I was a space geek
when I was a little kid I was making
solid fuel Rockets out of my mother's
used lipstick tubes when I was nine they
went about a hundred feet in the air
yeah I've been watching it for a long
time and it was a pleasure to have the
opportunity working with President Obama
and working with Charlie Bolden the NASA
Administrator Rockets outside of time to
know that they did a background check
and they found out that you blew things
up as a kid well I was a bit of a
problem but they decided to let me
through them
those wave you made rockets out of
lipstick tubes little solid fuel Rockets
yeah I had chemistry set ingredients
that made the solid fuel I made time
two's burned an inch a minute so I could
get away before it went off
next time I seen six-year-old boys in
Sephora I'll know what they're up to 101
things to do with lipstick - I'm sorry I
was very distracted by I apologize my
phone yeah okay I think I'm back on
track did we did get a lot done in
reshaping the priorities in NASA
more investments in the technologies
that would be needed to go to Mars you
know a lot of people are saying why
don't we go to Mars tomorrow yeah put
the money in and you know Neil as well
as I do that we don't yet have the
technologies to send people to the
surface of Mars and bring them back of
course there are some who are willing to
take a one-way trip and some others who
would be my candidates for a one-way so
you're citing NASA in response to my
question about the future is NASA the
repository of our future hopes among
agencies no it's only one day shift
happens to be particularly evocative one
and one that's still by the way inspires
young people in the way almost nothing
else in science does that the big
science fairs we've had in Washington
the two exhibits that always attract the
most attention are NASA and robots those
are those are the two that really do it
that get kids going about science and
technology so how do you draw the line
between the research you do that helps
invent the future and the research that
Congress will tell you you shouldn't be
doing because corporations should be
doing that as part of their R&D where's
that line there's got to be somewhere in
there well there is a there's a fairly
obvious line in fact the corporate
sector funds more than two-thirds of all
the R&D in this country but they fund
less than half of the basic research the
fundamental research that's a seed corn
from which all the reserves
and the reason the private sector
doesn't do that is perfectly
understandable time horizon is too long
the risk is too high the return is too
uncertain and they're not sure that if
there's a breakthrough from this basic
research that they the corporation that
paid for it will get the benefits and
the government needs to do it the
government needs to do that sort of
basic research needs to fund it yeah we
didn't get done when that happens
Congress stands up and says why is
taxpayer money being wasted of this
research that has no application to any
known thing on earth and of course there
are examples of some of this terrible
research well yeah then now I'll give
you something the nature of basic
research is you can't tell where it's
going to go great example Charles Townes
have got the Nobel Prize for thinking up
the science behind the maser and then
the laser had no idea when he did that
work that 50 years later lasers would be
the way we do eye surgery cut metal copy
documents play movies major distances
none of that was obvious at the time the
work was done we've amended the assets
of the moon with lasers folks
professional lasers are worth it here's
another great example there was a
science project funded by the National
Science Foundation many years ago was
called the sex life of the screwworm
yeah and under screwworm the sex life or
unscrew work and that's a real one every
worm
there was a lot of fun was made of this
in the Congress I think it got Senator
Proxmire as a Golden Fleece award in
fact and the award given to but the
greatest waste of money
and the fact is the screwworm was a
livestock pest that did some 100 million
dollars worth of damage every year to
the livestock industry in the United
States and this basic research on the
sex life of the screwworm led to a means
of biological control of the screwworm
which basically eradicated it as a
livestock theft immense savings to the
US economy was that just a marketing
failure though like should have been
called like save our agriculture
business research we don't get boat
against that people doing the research
didn't know that that would be the
outcome that's the nature of basic
research and then they put condoms on
the screw worms the solution was
actually somewhat similar to that the
solution was releasing sterile males cuz
it turns out that the screw worm only
made at once the female only made at
once and if the female mated with a
sterile male she was a nun no offspring
and so the idea is you just release it
you just release a ton of sterile males
yeah and the sperm I can't believe we
just
I apologize that's why you add for an
example but we know Corey that they're
people who don't in Congress both sides
of the both branches that don't
appreciate this
absolutely this there's people that
don't how do we get them to appreciate
again that's the that's the political
process that's the sort of sausage
making or screwworm funding it's not
just an education it's not just examples
like this no it's not why can't it why
can't he stand up give that example I
give you three others and they these are
intangible examples why doesn't that
convince people is there missing part of
the education 12 education where the
receptors aren't there for four examples
that might change their mind again it is
a this is a process in which there's
tons of competing demands and there are
people that are dead set against this
kind of science research and and don't
get the larger is it Chris dug in their
heels and that's it with respect
Neil I think you know I don't ever want
you to respect me Jen which would bring
up then with bland with extreme
disrespect you're you're coming at this
as a scientist and you're leaning on
these facts as if facts have ever always
been enough any parent knows that you
tell the kid a fact once why don't why
do they keep misbehaving I told them if
this happens this will be the
consequence but we do it because we have
emotions and we have tribalism and when
a feel a sense of belonging so I think
some of these reasons that people are
being obstinate information alone is
never enough to close the case and so
it's an important first step but you got
to build some layers on top of that
telecontrol in the day
it was falling I'm just curious about
that there are other branches of nets of
the government other than NASA I don't
know if they were in your portfolio but
DARPA is something we've always early on
Defense Advanced Research Projects
administration
hey there's arpa-e huh does DARPA e
which is which I'm very interested in
this about its investments in
alternative energy don't be for energy
yes yes so these are these are funded by
the Department of Defense yes okay now
arpa-e is funded by the Department of
Energy okay but they're both neither of
them are in OST PS OSTP has oversight of
all the Science and Technology no matter
no matter who's doing it oh okay and we
work together with the departments and
agencies in developing the President's
budget
you said robots get everybody's
attention at the behinds fair so
absolutely
I know dark has been making some robots
absolutely help just refrain all our
science as a weapon
yes but I mean one of the reasons why we
can get a lot of very good research done
through the Department of Defense
because it's often easier to get people
to fund the Department of Defense and it
is to get them to fund some of these
other agencies hoping that I don't want
to die perfect
if the screwer was a weapon there'd be
no problem there is a battle going on
right now about defense spending versus
domestic spending yeah and this idea of
should there be parity and the increases
in the life but I just have a question
because I got two scientists here and
something I've read a lot about when you
talk about larger planetary threats
isn't there a real threat of an impulse
for example a naturally occurring one
that could really knock out America's
infrastructure yes it's a short answer
yeah
people that wants this ignore
infrastructure tell everyone about our
hand pulse no Willie Wayte is gonna
matrix real matrix had and the impulse
to get rid of the robot squids that
squiddy the squid II think or they call
the Sentinels you guys didn't see the
major oh my god the subject so there are
two kinds of electromagnetic pulse one
is if you explode a nuclear bomb in the
atmosphere among many other things it
generates a pulse of electromagnetic
energy that can fry the electronics in
your cell phone and your car's ignition
in the controllers of the electricity
grid and so on so that's one of the many
good reasons not to explode nuclear
weapons in the atmosphere is that it
will ruin your version of an
electromagnetic pulse is when a solar
storm a solar flare a solar flare throws
charged particles in the direction of
the earth and they interact with the
Earth's magnetic field in a way that
generates a pulse of electromagnetic
energy at the surface and that too can
fry your phone your electricity grid and
everything else it's happened in modern
times it happened in a part of Canada
but it also happened there was an event
in the nineteenth century that if that
was so severe it knocked out Telegraph
over a very large area but there wasn't
much electrical equipment in those days
and so it didn't do that much damage but
we know that if an event of that
magnitude occurred today it would be
devastating to [ __ ] our country where
is all the Sun as a result of that
possibility we have invested now
substantial effort in trying to build a
multi-pronged strategy to protect us
from those kinds of events not to be
that strategy includes sensors on the
discover satellite to give us early
warning the strategy includes the
ability to disconnect parts of the
electricity grid on warning very quickly
but there are other things that we
should be doing and that the study
recommended that we do that we're not
yet doing right that's something that
I'm very glad your interest know this is
my point these things I read yeah too
much I read that okay that words not all
you should be worrying about so we
should be worrying about that as a globe
yeah when's this happening so there's
not only that there's there's always
talking about AI running amok and does
the United States have a major
investment in this the future of this
technology so we've basically gone from
the matrix to Terminator now but keep
going yeah let me ask you this we had
Ray Kurzweil as a guest on Startalk and
I was delighted by that conversation
because I'd only known of him from what
other people wrote and I finally got the
horse's mouth and and I loved the guy to
no end just he's a deep thinker
brilliant and so when I ask here's a lot
of talk about connecting human biology
to the Internet in some way so that your
brain is now actively processing the
world and do you see this biologically
as a real thing coming down the line I
think so I don't think it's yes yes I
don't think it's imminent I think that's
a way ways off but which steps were
steps they're already either this is
biologics you could put it inside of
yourself in them be able to monitor
distribute medicine all keep your doctor
could literally sit at a computer we're
getting close to that and be able to
deliver you doses of medicine based upon
the information they're getting over
distances about what's happening inside
your body
that's precision medicine we were
talking about it before all right so but
however they are
I now is making decisions that I didn't
authorize mm-hmm
right so the big fear is that AI and I
tweeted this once I said we better
behave because when AI achieves
consciousness we want to give it as
fewer reasons as possible to exterminate
us so is there an agency just thinking
about AI sure Shirley Loomis John Sarah
okay
yeah I mean we had many many meetings in
the White House about AI many of them
including President Obama who very
interested in it and concerned about it
did you write a paper on it it has an
upside upside in in terms of increasing
the capacity to get a lot of important
things done and as a downside like many
technologies if it's misused if it
evolves in a bad direction it could be
problematic and so the question is how
do you manage the evolution of this
technology in a way that gets the
benefits while minimizing the dangers
but my own view is that the dangers as
we currently understand them are being
overstated the proposition that
computers are going to become in some
general sense smarter than humans
sometime soon is not believed by many of
the experts in the field there's some
who think it will happen there are many
who think it won't happen that doesn't
mean we shouldn't be vigilant and trying
to figure out how to make sure that AI
doesn't evolve in a way that takes over
our line but can I tell you where AI
scares me right now and is real is that
our enemies sorry Eugene like Russia
just to be clear
sorry let me don't blame it if they win
this is so we have a real problem in
this country with cyberattacks and one
of the reasons one of the areas in which
AI technology is now being used
look Russia China will never beat us
tank for tank worshipful worship we
spend more money on military and bigger
military in the next 6-7 countries
combined but where they can now offer a
threat we just saw this with a massive
cyber attack is is with what the
advancements are be made in hacking and
that kind of technology and AI is being
used invested in explored by the Chinese
and the Russians as a way of having a
far more intelligent way where the
computer connect self begin to learn
about what the defenses are of a system
and better break into them and so when
you see our competitors and remember
it's not just Russia China who's doing
extraordinary jobs stealing business
technologies and the like using these
very sophisticated AI blockchain all
these these new next-generation sort of
technologies and innovations against us
and beating us to the punch
it's a massive vulnerability for our
nation that we should be very where does
that save us that would come under the
Department of Defense but but Department
defense other than the darker in the
darker II is not really as equipped it
seems to me to attract the the best of
the brightest to solve that problem well
yeah I don't think that's quite right
the Department of Defense includes the
National Security Agency National
Security Agency employs more PhD
mathematicians or any other organization
in the world they got it they are
thinking about AI extensively as is
DARPA which has a lot of smart folks as
well I'm not saying there's no problem I
agree with the senator this is a big
risk it's a big area of competition our
adversaries are very busy we're very
busy too by the way an AI can be used to
defend our cyber systems just as this
can be used by our adversaries to attack
them so this is an on going to put our
AI entry
and then just let them fight and we go
off go to the park yeah that's okay
that would be good yeah let me just get
into your lives for a moment each of you
left academic posts to serve in the
White House and is that your became a
sort of a citizen scientist servant of
an needs what what each of you what what
drove you to do that well for me there
were two factors one was John Holdren
and the other was Barack Obama okay
impressive intellects committed to
science and I think John convinced me
when we first talked about the position
that working for this president would be
a privilege beyond all else for
scientist and he was right it was an
honor to work for president who cared so
much about science so nine years ago
what were you thinking well first of all
I had had the good fortune to meet
President Eisenhower a second term
science advisor George Castilla Kowski
when I was 29 years old and he became
one of my mentors and I learned a lot
from him about his service for
eisenhower then I met Jerry Wiesner who
with JFK's science advisor and he became
a mentor and I ended up knowing every
science advisor to every US president
from Eisenhower on so so I got a secret
I had a secret ambition as a result of
all those interactions that I might
someday be a president science adviser
and I just happened to luck out and get
the best president in modern times to be
the science advisor to
if there were a president who you didn't
like but asked you to be his or her
science advisor
what would you say well it would depend
on the president why if you're asked to
advise them why should it depend on the
president it depends on you know you you
have you have to believe that the
president will listen you have to
believe if you're not in a fight if
you're not even in the room they're
clearly not listening to you because
you're not in the room that's true but
so then there's a chance to listen to
you if you're in the room you have to
figure out whether you're going to be
more effective advising this particular
president or more effective pursuing the
same issues from outside I'm out so you
have to make that decision it can't
always work to yell science into a wing
to say something that these two doctors
that's extraordinary and people should
recognize this the whole idea of our
country in the Declaration of
Independence which this genius document
but frankly had flaws it was you know
refer to Native Americans as savages and
all the flaws of the genius of the
writers at the time that they had flaws
but they kind of came to a conclusion at
the end where they basically said for
this country the idea of this nation
which was not sounded like other
countries because we all look alike or
pray alike or descended the same way
this was the idea of this country was of
the first nation of ideas and principles
and that's a tenuous especially then it
was a tenuous way of forming a nation
and so what these two doctors really
represent to me is what our founders
said is gonna have to happen if this
country is gonna make it they basically
said we have to have an unusual
commitment to each other that goes
beyond just tolerating each other or
kind of admiring each other they
basically said we have to commit to each
other and this is the final words the
declaration independence we must
mutually pledge to each other Our Lives
our Fortunes and our sacred honor and
it's something we all should think about
are we living our lives this way these
folks and they're very humble but trust
me they could have probably made a lot
more money a lot more resources rich
working in government get rich but these
are folks that said you know what my
love of this country my sacred honor my
commitment of my fortune
we'll be to this nation's goodness and
and it's been those folks who are those
irrational people throughout history who
may not even make it into the history
books
but if had consistently had this
commitment those people that built the
greatest infrastructure of the station
has ever known most of them whose names
aren't known the Underground Railroad
those people who I can't name the people
who whether they store beaches in
Normandy or or satin laboratories
designing technologies innovations that
I use every day but I take it I take for
granted and so I just want to thank them
publicly because they don't often get a
moment like this before a huge audience
hardly ever hardly ever to get the kind
of gratitude and celebration let's bring
up the house lights and we'll take some
to Annette we'll do this for like 20
minutes we got a few minutes I don't
know if we have microphones there's a
microphone on the aisle there and we
have another microphone on the aisle
there ok so who's the first person up
right there okay go ahead wait wait you
turn that on hang on
yeah we got it now go ahead Willie how
old are you how old are you six kilos
you're six
[Applause]
well welcome to Startalk I hope we
didn't use too much grown-up language
here yeah sometimes we do my apology I
apologize but I bet we didn't use any
language that you're that you never
heard your parents use you say so I bet
so what is your question hold the
microphone right in front of your mouth
yes supernovas
how do supermassive black holes form
[Applause]
it's a little off topic kid can you
answer that so high mass stars when they
die they leave behind the black hole as
a remnant you want to avoid that but
it's it's there there'll be many of
those across the galaxy but they're
black holes that are much more massive
than that one per galaxy in each galaxy
center and those we call supermassive
black holes and we don't really have a
good idea of how they form if you are in
that question now okay here's the
challenge when we are born the parents
spend the first few years teaching us to
walk and talk and then they spend the
rest of our lives telling us to shut up
and sit down clearly in your case
the curiosity is burning within you if
you carry that curiosity into adulthood
you may be the first person to discover
how supermassive black holes
[Applause]
yeah hello hello dr. Tyson senator buck
are everyone there on the panel thank
you very much for coming my question
well firstly let me say dr. Tyson you
said that you don't believe in hope but
I want to say something that we've all
probably heard since before Christmas is
that revolutions are built on hope so
also I want to ask senator Booker you
had mentioned about the Superfund sites
that we have throughout New Jersey and I
wanted to also discuss with you since
this is the Garden State and we like to
do a lot more of our own gardening and
you have mentioned trying to return more
to a plant-based diet many of the things
that we use in our own yards are not
good for the environment they're not
good for the food that we're eating and
they're not good for the things that we
use in our own gardens and what are you
doing as a senator to help us bring more
ecologically sound and more
environmentally sound things to our own
gardens that are not being you know
pushed as they should be
that's a great question we can broaden
that to say how what kind of things can
we and should we do locally that will
matter globally is that a fair extension
of that question sure so I don't
everybody know that there's a farm bill
reauthorization coming up it was days
when I came into the Senate that I voted
against it because of a lot of reasons
one it made a massive cut to food stamps
but also because they gave massive
subsidization to these massive
corporations who engage in farming
practices that are polluting the soil
looting our rivers and and and
subsidizing them with our tax dollars
subsidizing things that we tell
Americans not to eat our government on
one hand tells you not to eat this stuff
and then we're subsidizing on the other
hand so that when kids in you know I'm
going back home to Newark tonight when
kids in Newark walk into a bodega and
see a Twinkie product cheaper than an
apple it's because we're subsidizing
that stuff and the reality is then those
kids are getting type 2 diabetes as
children and we have to subsidize that
healthcare so what I'm saying is this
food system we have needs a lot of
repair and so what I believe in exciting
me that you're answering this question I
started when I was mayor I love this
idea of
locally-sourced things and we should be
encouraging that kind of agriculture in
our communities
the farm bill actually got some stuff in
there I think that was good about
locally grown organic stuff but I think
more but should be so the end of the
answer I would say is find out what's
happening with this coming big Parkway
authorization bill let's work together
you're one of my constituents reach out
to my office I have a group of people
that are very passionate on my staff
about this farm bill what we could be
doing to support the kind of local
farming you're talking about New Jersey
is one of the leaders in local farming
yes we're local farming we're farm state
and urban farming in fact when I was
mayor of Newark we created Newark is the
largest but everything yeah absolutely
acres and acres it's a good way to
banish food deserts and exciting stuff
is happening urban farming Roof Gardens
there's a company in New Jersey called
arrow farms which uses very little
vertical farming all these innovations
less water it's really exciting stuff
let's see if we can answer our questions
a little quickly because we have a
thousand trillion people online yes
right here for everyone but especially
Joe as a female scientist I have three
daughters ages 12 10 and almost 4 and
they start off really inquisitive and
and the six year old and they want to
know about black holes and and my
daughter my oldest is is in middle
school now and she has one in her
elementary school her science fair and
she was thought it was the coolest thing
and still into science and now in middle
school you could see that tapering off
and a disinterest for females especially
but for her in science and how do you
how do you propose that we keep that
curiosity as you have said and
especially for women because women don't
make up I work in a job who doesn't have
a whole lot of women either but that's a
construction how do we keep the women
wanting to do science when they're not
encouraged to do so well I think that's
a great question and we can all play a
role in that by encouraging girls to do
it and showing them role models one of
the reasons that girls turn away
science and middle schools they're
starting to come to grips with being
women and they think why have to be a
woman or a scientist because they often
don't see examples of normal healthy
exciting women that run marathons or
have kids or do whatever it is that
women do and so one of the things we
worked on the white house and then I
continued currently is how do we change
the image of Science and Technology in
Hollywood and I think they can play an
enormous role in inspiring our girls and
minorities to be scientists just by
showing the whole greps of scientists
and the jobs that they do so it's a
great question on a small scale we could
just encourage them and show them
examples
[Applause]
Emily I've spoken you once before you
probably don't remember me but I know
this is slightly off topic I was
wondering if I could have your autograph
[Laughter]
not sure I'd be happy to do it after the
show all right
I'll be happy to do it anywhere in that
secured towards that say something else
on it's a rogue NASA shirt it's a rogue
on it oh it's in the it's it's in the
spirit of what we're doing so give
something for me to sign to an usher and
I'd be happy to do it okay
my live desk
did you also have a question yes really
glad you did we try to keep the
questions quick so we can get through
the one go I get a Senator Booker yes um
I was just thinking I've talked with my
parents about this before for like the
younger generation what could we
possibly do besides just protesting like
I've been to a women's March but like is
there anything else that the younger
generation can do since we're basically
what's going to be the future of
politics and science why is it that the
most effective protests are only the
ones that turn violent because then they
make more headlines across the country I
disagree completely with that thing I do
too the most effective protests are the
ones that forge connections between
those who show up there one that changed
the narrative of how the media covers an
issue they're the ones that encourage
people to follow it with their protest
by voting by running for office
themselves by joining a local group
that's embedded in their community so
the violence is a spectacle it's often a
distraction forged by people who don't
want to see change happen that's not an
effective protest that's a failure and
it's disruption by those who oppose it
for young people want to do stuff
besides protest yo just be curious like
Neil said run for something like
represent your people somewhere whether
it's like your school board within your
school itself if you have the
opportunity to represent others that's
giving to other people and that you're
living what you're asking others to do
and that's the best way to kind of
change the world around you
stop asking others to do it and do what
the senator says do it yourself at the
level that you can achieve that's the
beginning
Protege single so I've been teaching
public school for eight years are my
students brains
this is depend of like abstract but are
they evolving using these cell phones
quicker than our brains used to without
them and how can I catch up with my
lessons to get them engaged you know
with this once they take it out they're
gone so how can you help me out with
that a little bit anybody it's a
biological thing yo you got a bike you
got a biological reply to that well you
have the wisdom of age I would go with
that
thank you we got some people up top that
want it Wow we have a microphone up
there I didn't see that I'm sorry all
right let's do it right here right there
go
I hear you yes I'm glad you do I work at
Motion Center for Independent Living and
I'm wondering what policy and what
policy and science can do for the
welfare of people living with
disabilities exciting things for I think
they're really exciting things coming
forward using technology to compensate
for what people can't do either because
of age or a disability and I think that
technology is really going to be
developing fast in the next few years
because the demand for it will be
increasing as our citizenry ages so I
think it's a really great time for those
kinds of questions but I think we need
to look at how people actually live and
there are some studies that use virtual
reality to study how people actually
live in their homes or wherever they
live and and then develop technology
around that and I think that's much more
accurate than trying to imagine how
people live which is unfortunately how a
lot of that research has been done in
the past a lot of assumptions well plus
would be a difference between supporting
someone who has a disability and then
repairing the disability right right
which the principle could happen one day
yes and then we all live a life we live
active lives until we die rather than
active lives until we get infirmed and
then staying firm until we die that it
won't be too long before were 3d
printing new organs so that the organ
waitlist that now exists for
transplanted organs will become a thing
of the past because we can 3d print new
organs the second thing that knows for
nerves
is a different time but it's happening
so it takes more toner than usual and
for the Nerds out there who are
interested in this particular question
the President's Council of Advisors on
science and technology did a report in
the past year on technology to assist
with aging which doesn't address all of
the questions that the questioner had in
mind but it addresses some of them and
that report is online in the Obama
archive ok cool so as a college student
I actually go to Imagineering the
University and I was just wondering
mister tightening senator Brucker what
do you think your opinion is on how
college students out of college after
graduation can get that experience to
make those changes in the science and
technology field do you want to enter do
you want to become a scientist or become
a I'm actually an aerospace engineering
major at Stephenson
I also have a tattoo of Pluto that if
you want to roast me for so are you
asking what pathway might you take to
the service has my two esteemed
colleagues here have been yeah you know
you're applying for LS internships
there's giant pools of ya applicants
just what do you guys think well it's
interesting you first of all depending
on your level you can apply for some of
the very interesting fellowships in
science and public policy the triple AAA
fellowships the American Chemical
Society fellowships the other thing you
can do is you can just present yourself
in an office we hired some folks at OSTP
who just walked in the door and said
we'd like to help some of them walked in
the door and said we're so interested in
helping we'll help for nothing we took
those first of course and some of them
did such wonderful work we decided to
pay them so you basically need to step
up and have the confidence that if you
present yourself and talk about what you
want to do and what you could do you may
well get a post one policy request that
you could really help me with because
something I'm fighting for but if you're
a stem subject person frankly college
folks in New Jersey really face this
threat and you want to go in in public
service and do things like this you
should not have college debt and it's
something we need to do as a country
stepping up because again our
competitors Germany and I go through the
nation's who are dramatically lowering
the cost of colleges and universities so
thank you for your desire to serve and
this nation B should be liberating you
from the tens of thousands of dollars of
debt it meant that our average college
graduates are carrying and I want to
pick up on a point John made there
aren't for so many jobs that you see
that are that type I'd luminosity there
is no actual path that guarantees you
will land in those spots often it is the
ten
city of the person who ultimately
occupies that spot that got them there
so you know you can't be get an actor
and say I want to be a famous actor just
like this person what do I need to do
I'll do exactly what they did because
what they did may have been a unique
path to that point you got to find what
beat might be the unique path for you
and is it interning at an aerospace
company that actually has people in
Washington who are talking to members of
Congress there so it's it's not a
pre-scripted it's not a pre-scripted
route and it takes the tenacity at each
point at each pivot point of your career
to ask yourself what do I need to do
whether or not someone has done that
before you well the great example is
John who stalked everybody who had his
job before question can I possibly get a
picture with you and that awesome best
I'm wearing a shirt with your face on it
almost every shirt that exists out there
with my face on it is like bootleg so so
if you if you come down I thought it'd
be here it's gonna take a picture okay
we only have time for like a couple more
questions before we call it quits let's
go right here yeah um you know we talked
about making America
smart again but every time I go online I
see a lot of stupidity that's rampant a
lot of it's irrational my conspiracy
theory is earth that's flat we didn't go
to the moon you know we got 9/11
truthers GMO stuff how can we as a
society can bat that really irrational
stupidity yeah let me offer reflection
but then I'll defer to my panelists here
so the Internet is the greatest access
to knowledge there ever was but you also
have this delusion that no matter your
thought if you type in a search for it
you will find everyone else in the world
who has as crazy a thought as you just
typed in validating what you think is
real because of how many other people
share their view and so the search
engines with that maybe they should say
do you realize
do you really want to search this are
you do you take this breathalyzer before
we send you heavy what's missing yeah
you know what's missing internet savvy
101 in school all right
somewhere in school you got to be taught
that some information is more likely to
be true than others depending on its
source okay it's at some point we need
to learn that and it's not in the k-12
curriculum
last I checked so that's a problem and
the flat earthers I you know I don't
have a problem this a free country you
just say what you want think what you
want you want to think the earth is flat
go right ahead but try not to become
head of NASA if you think that way
plenty of jobs for you if you want to
think the earth that's what plenty of
jobs you can have so so yeah if this
keeps up Cory I don't know what the
future of the country is if this kinds
of anti scientific thinking spreads
become sort of infectious then we just
go over the waterfall we've got to be
the antibiotics then match the lies with
truth fight it just as hard it's it's
just like technologies of old television
radio it's a it's a it's a neutral
platform where a lot of people are
getting on it's a contest of ideas and
we've got to match those lies with truth
and and be purveyors of it
[Applause]
hi so I wanted to know what your
thoughts were on the event horizon
telescope and the possible recent
photography of a black hole for the
first time and you know that the hole
will look the way we think it looks so
you think will be anything not unknown
there maybe you're right so Corey can
you take this you know I actually know
very little about that telescope about
photographing black holes black holes
alone are not very photogenic
but black holes can render their
existence visible by indirect means for
example in the flaying of a star whose
outer layers are spiraling down within
and then that toilet bowl style sucking
action is it radiates copiously in
ultraviolet and x-rays and use an
ultraviolet telescope and an x-ray
telescope and they pick them out all
across the galaxy so it's just a
testament to the methods and tools of
science that demonstrate that the five
senses that we are biologically endowed
with are wholly inadequate to decode the
actual operations of nature and so
that's what telescopes do for us but
otherwise I'm not I'm not up on the
event horizon telescope I'm in backs I
should know but I'm like to be candid in
my ignorance yeah there it is thanks for
not try to pass laws based on that
ignorance I appreciate that yeah yeah
you should just be self aware of that
yeah and not try to create legislation
based on it Wow am I is the senior next
year I'm going to school to study
physics in a large part due to you and
the things that you put out there oh
well thank you so thank you my questions
for you and senator Booker someone once
told me you can't reason someone out of
something they didn't reason themselves
into how do you fight that and I thought
that when it's evolution or public
policy r-right yeah I think that same is
like 85% true and so I think it implies
that winning an argument involves reason
but winning an argument can involve
demonstration right
if someone doesn't think there's global
warming you just invite them to buy
property on the ocean's edge they
convert very quickly and you didn't have
to lay down a single argument so so I
think there are ways of convincing
people that don't involve logical
arguments and this we need to be more
savvy about what method might be best
invoked given the person given the
situation and I as an educator invest a
stupid amount of energy mental energy
thinking about what are what are the
what are the thought pathways that
occupy the person who I'm communicating
with and I then align what I'm trying to
say with those thought pathways so that
I can maximally send the information in
to you on a level where you can take
ownership of it and you can say wow I
never knew it that way oh my gosh I
figured it out I understand it now
that takes a key and sometimes there's
different key for every single person
and that's hard that's a higher level of
expectation from an educator
than just lecturing against a chalkboard
hoping that you walk up behind and pick
it up and understand what's going on one
piece of quick advice for me real quick
and I learned this the hard way when I
was done I finally had this aha moment
so this is simply the piece of advice
you do not have to attend every argument
that you are invited to
[Laughter]
we've got another person who by the way
you have one of the very few official
shirts issued by Startalk
yes that's looks yes go on a question
get close to the mic I as a middle
school student and many other middle
school students out there are being told
to sit down and shut up
more than ever why is that and what
could we do about it yeah so you're in
middle school now yes I am in eighth
grade so I'm gonna be going into high
school soon yeah yeah so your teachers
are saying the good students are the one
that are quiet and obey ya to a point
some allow questions some don't do it
extend yeah so one of the challenges to
the middle school teacher is that you
all are hormonal or ammonia leak crazy
at this point we're Monali are modeling
hormonal
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so you know I can't go in there and like
slap the teachers eye but if you know
that your curiosity and your energy for
life and exploration is a good thing
then sure behaved in class but when you
get out of class misbehave you have my
permission to do that do you realize in
a few years I'm gonna publish a book
don't ask me about it until it come on
the publisher book that will contain my
academic record in it and it will
contain comments from my elementary
school teachers who complained
constantly that my energy was disrupting
the class I was a bad student for that
reason and I was not the teacher's pet
the teacher's pet was the person who was
quiet got high grades and exactly obeyed
everything the teacher said and I had
this energy and I would subtract jokes
and I would I would show people stuff
and I bring the urban equivalent of a
frog to class disruption
so none of those teachers would have
said he'll go [ __ ] with Lenovo from not
about did you bring Street rats to class
[Laughter]
like I said you'll spend many more hours
outside of school than in school so use
the time outside of school to misbehave
all you want and that then there's the
secret to becoming something greater
than the student who obeys every single
command that a teacher hands do forgive
me but we have time only for one more
question we're going to take it right I
just want to say to that young lady it
can I just say real quick I'm sorry ruff
Oh to the aged you'll have to come back
to the microphone but look there are a
lot of time so they even in the United
States Senator where I have to shut up
and and be silent and there are times
where I don't want to be but my only
thing simple point to you and you said
it in the larger context but allow
somebody in authority you have to go
through life they can silence your voice
but never let them silence your spirit
that has got to continue ladies and
gentlemen of the evening I'm sorry for
everyone else online yes go hello I want
to ask like a question about
microbiology like something that you
were I'm in allow an honors lab bio
class for a freshman year so we have a
current event that we have to do every
15th of the month so I found one that
had to do with bacteria in your mouth
could have something for your risk of
cancer and it mentioned microbiology in
there and I wanted to know like how
could it affect cellular division and
something like that
well I don't think we know the answer to
that in that specific case but there are
a lot of proposals for how bacteria
would be influencing things like cell
division or cancer or other other events
and partly it's the things they produce
they produce chemicals and those
chemicals can then induce cells to do
different things
and in other cases it's because they
allow some other organism into the human
system that then induces something else
so there are a lot of different
mechanisms some of them not so direct
what we I think are beginning to
understand a little bit more about those
one that came out really recently was
really interesting that bacteria that
get out of the gut
sometimes because of permeability in the
wall sometimes will incite an immune
response that ends up killing a tumor so
that's the kind of thing nobody ever
anticipated as being a mechanism for
suppressing cancer also recently didn't
use success not you necessarily
successfully create a poop transplant
one person and put it in another person
makes them better so so these micro
biomes are doing way more than we ever
imagined absolutely and keeping us
healthy is the biggest thing they do so
remember that next time someone calls
them germs will call the microbes
microbes good Micro what's their book
called microbes and Men yes I think we
titled microbes and women
there you go
so let me just good down the line here
before we close this out and just one by
one if you could what would be your
recipe for making America smart again
just yeah I guess voting voting for
science and also I think things like the
science March right I think I'm
optimistic in the end I think that you
can forward good things and over time if
it will work is sort of so I think
science mark get the job done I believe
in the American dream I adore it no fear
you know I think we we talk a lot about
like right now everyone's stressed out
by what's going on and they're like how
am I gonna deal with the client
self-care I'll go to do some meditation
and yoga I think we've just stopped
focusing on ourselves I think we have to
focus on other people that may in our
community and think outside of ourselves
more often and think about how we are
together rather than just laying down
and going ten minutes of headspace is
going to make it all better
I'm gonna build on what ephyra has said
and suggest as I've done elsewhere that
everybody who is in science in
technology or who cares about Science
and Technology should tithe 10% of their
time whatever else they do tithe 10% of
their time to talking with other people
to engaging on how and why science and
technology matter to our society to our
well-being to the world what science is
how it works what the sources of
credibility in science are and why we
need to preserve and protect science we
need all of us to be better storytellers
about this to be activists to be engaged
in the policy process thank you for
having me here it's no I'm serious it's
been an incredible honor to be on stage
with these civil servants whether it's
the comedic arts and arts and sciences
and I'm humbled to be a part of this I
want to echo what Eugene said I happen
to be in a meeting of the organizers of
the science March and one of them cited
a Niels Bohr quote quantum physics
pioneer and I'm gonna paraphrase it but
he essentially described science as the
steady reduction of prejudice and if you
think about what science actually is you
constantly challenge what you think to
be true and replace it to which you know
to be true well and if you're not
constantly challenging that's not
science so we've been challenged up here
I encourage folks out there to do it and
I think what's coming up with the
science March whether it's you know
before during or after is a testament to
something much larger than the politics
of the moment it's about the larger
pursuit of science which is the
reduction of all of our prejudices
work
I guess I just would encourage people to
as Eugene said to be people of hope but
what I mean by that is I think this last
hundred days has been some of the most
hopeful period in my time as a senator
and and it's not because the situation
looks great but no I spent eight years
living in these high-rise projects in
Newark and the tenant president there
let her son murdered in in the lobby of
the building which I lived in she was
one of most hopeful people that I met
and and I and basically what she taught
me was that hope doesn't exist in the
abstract it's always a response to
despair it's saying that despair will
not have the last word and and that hope
also is not a being word you don't just
sit in a state of being this whole hope
isn't active it's a fighter it is
constantly working to create that belief
that that they that you haven't
surrender and so my my hope is that I've
seen the greatness of my country whether
it was the women's March or how that
health care bill which was so awful was
beat back not by politicians but by a
public Republican and Democrat who just
said there's no way we're gonna tolerate
that and so right now I my prayer is
that everybody remembers those ten two
letter words that this country will will
succeed or fail based on those ten two
letter words in those ten two letter
words is if it is to be is up to me I
have got to be an agent of hope and
that's that's sort of my parting word
one of the things I found really
striking today was what we talked about
things that excite the public about
science
it was either because of fear or
inspiration and I think we need to find
a way to explain science and teach
science in in logical ways not not fear
mongering but that either incite fear or
people's imaginations and inspiration
and it can't be just discovering new
planets and discovering new cures it has
to go way beyond that to all of science
and I don't know how to do that but I
would challenge all of us to think about
that how do we inspire people about the
fundamental quest for knowledge which is
the basis of science can offer some
final reflections here have you guys
said almost say anything I would have
said so you really left me with nothing
but let me share with you personally I
tried not to have hope because hope is
the confession that you have no control
of the outcome and I don't ever want to
cede that to a word I want to say to
myself there's an outcome that I have
some access to some control over and let
me reiterate again why I don't I don't
beat back politicians there's something
else deeper than that and in our K
through 12 system what do we do I think
we view students as these vessels will
you unzip their brain their hand and
pour information in for 12 years and
then you zip it back up hand them to
diploma and send them off and so we
think that being educated is knowing
stuff when somewhere in there one ought
to be taught how to question knowledge
how to evaluate information and evidence
these are the foundations of science we
don't even have to call it science let's
just call it curiosity because what is a
scientist but a kid who would never
really grew up all right it's it's a kid
who in adulthood retained childlike
curiosity and when you were chained
childlike curiosity anything that
happens before you is up for questioning
and you say well why are you doing it
that way can it happen this way well let
me research that and if you in addition
to being trained how to think about
information you're if somehow we can
retain your curiosity from childhood
through adulthood retain that curiosity
then you become lifelong learners
lifelong inquisitors because we will
spend many more years outside of school
than
in school how many people do we know if
not among ourselves the last day of
school you take your books throw them
into the air and say school's done as
though that's the state you want to be
and where you no longer have to learn
that's a failure of the educational
system you should come out of school say
gee I'm still curious can I go back in
work in some ways I can keep learning
and I think that if we read an entire
generation of people that are curious
into adulthood
then you will never elect someone who
just States things that are not true
that kid that would never happen
[Applause]
bill into the system curiosity and
witness the polyp to turn the politics
layers on top of that all right so you
don't say there is no global warming we
know there is all right
so now that we know there is let's have
the poll the political conversation are
there carbon credits there are do you
[ __ ] do you subsidize do you put up
Terrace that's where the politics needs
to happen not at any level below that so
my sense of this is we want to make
America great first have to make it
smart and to make it smart we have to
retain the curiosity that we all had as
children and that way we can turn a
sleepy country into an innovation nation
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Yuji
thank you all in Jersey always keep
looking up
[Applause]
[Music]